OF THE NAVY, A SCATHING CRITIQUE
FOR HIS OLD BOSS, THE PRESIDENT.
WE BEGIN WITH CORRESPONDED
KEVIN CORKE NEAR THE PRESIDENT'S
FLORIDA RESORT.
>> CALL IT OPERATIONAL SECURITY,
CALL IT SECRET, BY ANY
DEFINITION, THE PRESIDENT'S
VISIT TO AFGHANISTAN WAS A VERY
WELCOME SURPRISE FOR SOME OF THE
MANY AMERICAN TROOPS STATIONED
ABROAD THIS THANKSGIVING
HOLIDAY.
>> I HOPE EVERYONE ENJOYED
THANKSGIVING MEAL.
>> SOME 50,000 FEET ABOVE THE
FRIGID WILD BLUE, A WARM WELCOME
IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> WE LOVE HIM, WE SAY HAPPY
THANKSGIVING.
>> THE SURPRISE TRIP TO SEE U.S.
SERVICE PERSONNEL THIS HOLIDAY,
A WELCOME TREAT FOR TROOPS ON A
DAY WE ALL PAUSE TO GIVE THANKS.
>> MILLIONS OF FAMILIES SIT DOWN
AT THEIR DINNER TABLES BACK
HOME, THEY WILL BE SAYING A
PRAYER FOR THE MEN AND WOMEN
SERVING OUR NATION IN
AFGHANISTAN AND DEPLOYED ALL
AROUND THE GLOBE.
>> IT WAS IN MANY RESPECTS LIKE
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN BEFORE, PLENTY
OF PHOTOS, A BIT OF GOOD-NATURED
BANTER AND SERVICED BY THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
TO THOSE WHO IN BEING HERE HAVE
ALREADY SACRIFICED SO MUCH.
HIS REMARKS HAD ON FAMILIAR
THEMES TOO, A STRONGER THAN EVER
MILITARY, THE REMOVAL OF
TERRORISTS FROM THE BATTLEFIELD
AND THE LIKE.
HE USED HIS TRIP TO MEET HIS
PRESIDENTIAL COUNTERPART
ANNOUNCING THE U.S. AND TALIBAN
HAVE RESTARTED PEACE TALKS WITH
THE U.S. INSISTING ON A
CEASE-FIRE.
>> THE TELE- BAND WANTS TO MAKE
A DEAL AND WE ARE MEETING WITH
THEM AND WE ARE SAYING IT HAS TO
BE A CEASE-FIRE, THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO DO A CEASE-FIRE BUT NOW
THEY DO WANT TO DO A CEASE-FIRE.
>> THIS AFTER THE U.S. WITHDREW
FROM PEACE TALKS IN SEPTEMBER
AND THE PRESIDENT SAID HE'S
FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH HIS
CAMPAIGN PROMISES TO DRAW DOWN
AMERICAN TROOP LEVELS
SUBSTANTIALLY TO ABOUT 8600.
>> THAT'S THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ARE TALKING ABOUT, YES.
[REPORTER QUESTIONING]
>> IT IS FOR NOW, WE CAN GO MUCH
FURTHER THAN THAT.
>> KEENLY AWARE THAT THE FUTURE
WILL FEND FOR ITSELF, THIS WAS A
DAY TO REMAIN VERY MUCH IN THE
PRESENT, A CHANCE TO CAP A
JOURNEY SHROUDED IN SECRECY,
WITH A VERY PUBLIC DECLARATION
OF SUPPORT.
>> THERE'S NO WHERE I WOULD
RATHER CELEBRATE THIS
THANKSGIVING THEN RIGHT HERE
WITH THE TOUGHEST, STRONGEST,
BEST, AND BRAVEST WARRIORS ON
THE FACE OF THE EARTH.
>> RIGHT NOW BETWEEN 12 AND
13,000, THAT'S DOWN A COUPLE OF
THOUSAND FROM THIS TIME A YEAR
AGO, THE PRESIDENT MAKING VERY
CLEAR THAT THE U.S. WILL REMAIN